For a rocket and
an external force,
we had the rocket
equation, which
we wrote as mass of the
rocket-- now remember,
this is a function of
time-- times the derivative
of the rocket dr dt.
And we also had this
second term that
came from the ejecting fuel.
Now from our mass
conservation equation,
we can rewrite this equation
as a differential relationship
that the change of mass
of the fuel in time
is equal to minus the
change of the rocket.
It doesn't matter which side
we put the minus sign on.
So now I want to interpret this
equation in a different way,
and it will come back to
what we mean by our system.
Let's first off bring this
other term over to this side.
So we have plus dMr dt u.
And that's equal to Mr dVr dt.
Now separately, let's make this
substitution again and go back
to our fuel term.
So that's minus dMf
dt u equals Mr dVr dt.
Now notice that over
here we have mass times
the acceleration of the rocket.
So if we just rethought our
system as simply the rocket--
Mr-- then we have two
forces acting on the rocket.
The external force might
be the gravitational field,
but we have a new
term here which we're
going to refer to as thrust.
And so our thrust can be
thought of as an external force
simply on the
rocket as a system.
And that's equal to
minus the f dt u.
Now again, if I chose
j-hat up-- let's
just look at this
in components--
then our thrust
as a vector, we'll
write it as a y-component,
is equal to minus dMfuel dt.
Now what is that relative speed?
Well, the fuel is being
ejected backwards,
so that's minus mu j-hat.
The external force, by the
way, would be minus mg j-hat
if it's near the
surface of the Earth.
So we have another
minus u j-hat.
And we see that we
have a positive thrust
force in the vertical
direction that
is giving us an additional force
other than the gravitational
field.
And in Cartesian-- in
our unit vectors here,
we have minus mg plus dMfuel
dt times u is equal to Mr dV
ydt of the rocket.
And so this is the rocket
equation in components.